welcome back momo uh thank you hi
welcome
nice to see you again good so so what's
what's going on since the
last time you shot a video with me when
you were working the street on figure
out
um i haven't been i haven't been working
the street anymore
and why is that because my family has
been telling me like
to let go of it and i've been struggling
from working from street because i've
been needing to
get money to help my family out with the
bills and stuff your mom was telling me
you were trying to support
your family yeah you keep offering to go
out there but yeah but what have you
been doing
um i've been doing hair i've been going
outside like um walking my dog each and
on
every day and just doing hair mom have
been giving me clients and stuff to get
here and i'm working on making my
website to
wear my hair so i could post hair and
everything and yeah
and how does this feel for you good i
feel happier because like
i don't got to go out to go make any
more money and
i gotta worry about nobody trying to
come get at me or anything you know
it's a safer life yeah doing hair than
working the street as a prostitute right
how does it make you feel about yourself
good because
i feel satisfying because i have to
deal with nobody having to want money
for me and i could just keep money to
myself you know
and yeah like i could splurge my money
on myself
i'm gonna worry about nobody no it's not
just about money it's also about how you
feel about yourself myself yeah you know
if you meet a nice boy that you like
yeah you're going to feel much better
about that how you interact in that
relationship
so yeah when you're doing hair than when
you're
having sex with strangers right and i'm
trying to build up
my hair point so i can be able to tell
my mother out on stuff she need
you know so who steered you clear of
what you're doing huh
who who helped you get out of what
you're doing my mom mainly but my uncle
mainly because he
my mom too but my uncle he was the main
one who was like telling me
that i need to work on it and i need to
work on myself and stop trying to go
on the streets and stuff and stop trying
to
do everything everybody else doing and
worry about yourself
and stuff and just don't go out on the
streets to stay in the house and try to
find a better way to work on myself
and how old are you now i'm 15 i just
turned 15. 15.
uh august 31st i turned 15. so when you
shot that video with me last time you
were
old 14 14. yes and uh
you're still in high school are you
ready yes i'm still in high school yes i
go to school each and ever today i just
got out of school
but yeah i go to school on my phone zoom
and that's what you do
and i got back in school so i'm working
on getting me on my laptop from school
and stuff
yeah that's great yeah so how how has
this
affected your life in other ways i mean
other than how you feel about yourself
um like one of your friends my friends
happy
my friends like wow you accomplished
something that we didn't think was going
to accomplish our stuff
and i was like yeah how many people get
out how many huh not many people get out
yeah you're right that's what that was
telling me i've seen people out yeah i
see you younger yeah i already know
it's worse out there but it's like
people get addicted to
even if they're not making money yeah
and then you get addicted to the streets
and to people attention and all other
stuff
so i feel better and then drugs come
into the picture yeah and everything
else and you're
beat yeah fights yeah it ain't no joke
it's like a trap he's a real trap so
yeah
i just been working on myself and yeah
i'm proud of myself
but i'm working on my hair page but i
wanted to shout myself out to it
because me before i was already doing
hair but now
to see me doing my hair and i'm doing a
lot of people here and they come over
they like their hair
i feel better than myself like i'm gonna
go out to show nobody in my body just to
get some money or whatever yeah well you
and myself make sure you got some kind
of like website or something that you
can throw up when this video
shop appears in a week or so
right well i'm proud of you darling
thank you
it's nice to hear a positive story
that's great
okay all right thanks for coming back
you're welcome
okay okay
you're so cute thank you